The Bachelor or The
Bachelorette there's no line that makes
me laugh more on that show I know what
you're going to say than when I don't
believe he's here for the right reason
yeah like but I'm just saying like if
you legitimately want to find a life
partner if you legitimately want to find
somebody that you connect with that you
could share with that you could
procreate with that you can live with
that you can become one with is it
really on TV on a TV show where you're
you know it's happened and lasted yeah
it yeah well have been born I I I agree
with you in the sense that the fact that
the show is sold as your a last chance
at love I think is comical it's just
like if if it the bachelor is not a
place where it's not a last resort and I
I wouldn't I wouldn't recommend it to
someone I cared about to find love it is
a place that people have found love and
I do think in defense of the show for
all the people who critique um the poor
track record of the relationships that
start I mean like where where do people
have a good track record right most
relationships it's not any less
successful why you go on why did you go
on uh for the experience I thought it
you know not for the exposure I I was a
kid at the time I was selling software
in Chicago and I thought be you know I
that I'm being genuine I say this but
like to me would have thought it would
be cool if I was stopped by the local
news and and was on the 5:00 news as
witness number three I would have been
like that been cool no I agree and so
when I got the call I I had never been
out of I've only my experience of
traveling who had been to Dominican
Republic in Mexico i' had never been to
Europe or Asia very so much about the
bachelor is traveling the world right so
I thought well this you know and when I
first when I first got asked I only said
yes because I had never been LA and I I
genuinely thought I would say no because
I had a job that I loved a job I cared
about and a job I wasn't willing to lose
and so I really just said yes to the
casting process like well I'm not going
to do this show but maybe I'll get a
free trip to LA and and it would be kind
of cool to see what the casting process
is like and as I went through the
casting process I realized that they
liked me and they actually might ask me
to do the show and then I I was lucky
enough to have relationships with the
people I worked with where I just like a
few people I trusted and I said hey man
like so there's a show called The
Bachelor and and they're like and to my
surprise everyone and I I was had good
relationships with important people in
the company to my surprise uh they all
told me I should do it and I was lucky
enough that they valued me as an
employee and allowed me to do that and
keep my job so I I get it so it's not
because you know you've been longing for
the partner of a lifetime and you really
thought it to be on TV everybody wants
to be on TV I'm always fascinated like
on Cops which doesn't really tape
anymore I don't think but people were
always willing not at The Shining Moment
to sign a release like this right or
cheaters or something or cheaters yeah
but just to be on TV and I get it cuz
I'm a guy who wanted to be and probably
still wants are you the father you but
what I'm saying is that kind of
epitomizes yeah what we all want and we
want to be recognized and we want to be
stopped and you want to stand behind the
weather man and wave and people are
happy to be part of the audience and
they can't wait to see themselves you
know at AGT we always the warm-up guy
going you know you're going to be on
this episode like if you you know
everybody cheer and they're excited to
be part of the show and so that's why
people get on there so when you when I
see them trying to sell me that you're
or or especially when I see a guy crying
about you know she likes him and he's
not here for the right reason and it's
about me I go what the [__] are you
thinking after like one episode after
one episode and also to think like if
you really want to partner with somebody
don't you want to really bring somebody
into your real world I mean you probably
live in a in a one-bedroom apartment in
the city someplace and I'm not knocking
one that's I grew up like that but but
but here you are on a uh a palacial
Caribbean vacation somewhere that you
know I can't afford to do and this is
this is the world that they surround you
in so this is nothing about it is real
nothing you're never going to match that
world that they give
you yeah that's a common thought I I
don't you don't agree no in the sense
that like well and and you know you
asked me why I on the show Once I
decided to go on the show I said to
myself well if I'm going to be here I'm
going to immerse myself in the world I'm
going to be open to getting to know this
person and and see if there's something
there I'm not going to you know try to
fall in love but I'll be open to it uh
and to your point yeah you get to do
some really cool experiences but all the
all the dates that seem like you know
the helicopter rides and all that
there's so much production in there that
you actually it's just really hard to
have a conversation it's really hard to
build a connection and it's the dates
that feel more real life like walking
through a city and stopping at stores
that you know actually have the most
value but yeah I mean yes you're not
building you on The Bachelor whoever
wins you're spending if you were to add
up all the minutes you know it's it's
it's a relationship built on withholding
love rather than actually spending time
you spend M with each other you have a
little bit of a spark and they pull you
away from each other and so you spend
most of your time building up these
relationships in your head and
fantasizing about it and falling in love
with the idea of someone rather than the
person and everyone who gets engaged in
that on that show they they feel real
feelings people ask me what's the thing
I learned most about the show and I
first first couple years I'd answered
the question be like well not really I
mean I'm the same person yada ya but
after thinking about it most I think the
thing I learned the most on that show is
that feeling in love and being in love
can be two different things you your
feelings can be lot you can you can it
can feel like love but in reality it's
maybe infatuation or it's like a spark
or you know things like that where you
know depending how you define love you
know you a real emotional connection a
trust to knowing people's weaknesses and
knowing who they really are and what
makes them vulnerable you can't you
can't possibly learn all that in this
world so everyone who gets to the end
they're really basing their feelings off
of kind of fighting everyone off and
they you know the people who get to the
end truly feel like they have foughten
they have foughten off all these other
suitors and things like that even the
lead feels like they had to fight
through a bunch of people they didn't
really want to talk to but they were
forced to talk to only to finally be
with the person they want to be with and
then it's just a it's a coin flip you
know you have real feelings but you
don't really know what these real
feelings real feelings are so you agree
to date them in the real world and see
if you were right and most people
realize they're not your person and you
break up
he